hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dark echo now this game
is entirely based on echolocation and if
you can see from the title those aren't
just worms squiggling all around that's
kind of the style of the game you are
it's hard to describe I'll let the game
speak for itself because I'm not an
expert anyway so you are simply walking
around and using that to navigate the
hallways that you're in so if I'm
walking it's kind of like that I can't
remember what the game that I played a
few months ago was but it's kind similar
thing you you sound there's a way to
visualize the environment around you
whereas that one whose 3d this one is
top-down and supposedly now I'm not on a
percent on this but I'm supposedly
there's some horror element oh oh god I
wanna stomp my feet like that oh oh it's
beautiful oh that is that literally is
beautiful the way it all bounces around
like that oh that's so cool I got damn
but I'm saying it again I'm doing that
thing where I say how cool it is and
it's cool
very bounce ya gotta build it up maybe a
little bit thing okay alrighty then
oh that's so bizarre the way they tend
roll off into the darkness whoa whoa hey
is it a cave-in over there or something
point am I gonna have to be quiet
eventually probably that's not my style
but the other game it tapped into the
microphone which was like a totally
different experience because it made it
like a different level of immersion and
especially made it difficult for less
players because we had to talk it
apparently we could cause okay we made
it out of that one bizarrely enough dad
death I thought it was gonna be a hide
or something it was like escaped death
big jump between the two alrighty then
how is death going to approach
ah okay so that would be death if I went
down there I just have to be mindful of
the places of death well huh what is
that what is that I don't like the sound
of that I don't like the sound of
anything here
ooh their dead body there oh so it's not
my death we were talking about it's the
death of others who were too stupid to
not walk into a bunch of death yeah this
is so cool though fear oh no bring it on
I'm a master of fear I'm a master of all
my emotions most of all huh Oh God how
do I run oh [ __ ] oh God
ah the sounds of my doom echo through
the hallways holy [ __ ]
okay okay let's try that again let's go
this way
oh I don't know how to run okay we're
fine everything's fine everybody don't
panic the last thing we need is
panicking oh [ __ ] Oh
if you tiptoe it'll eventually good
yes yes yes don't slay yes don't slay me
okay yeah that's so cool I got them it's
it's it's really neat oh wow how so [ __ ]
we're being hunted now okay oh let's be
super stealthy about this copán
oh no it's oh that's you okay
move it along nothing to see here
get out and beaten baton baboo I've been
where a long time ago no no no no ah
that would have been death whoa I'm
skirting right along the edge of death
but it's a good thing that I'm very
smart about this
and I know exactly what I'm doing at all
times so I'm never going to be worried
about death
I lose it sorry ah okay we just got to
be careful calm and collected about it
nice nice nice okay
you should be fun yeah baby
Oh - oh this is nice this game is on
Steam and I believe it only costs like
three or four dollars but I don't know
how long the game is you never really
know if these indie games but this is
innovative it's new it's interesting
it's fascinating whoa what is that what
is that uh-huh so I touch it
oh okay it was a switch it was like a
button that's ooh sorry
water droplets make me sneeze alrighty
then
oh is that good that exit that's exit
but it seems to be blocked off so
there's got to be some way to open that
up maybe maybe some way around it nice
okay got that right so if we go yeah mmm
what the hell is with all the sound
being trapped in there that's nice
though but super cool that's ah [ __ ]
it's so cool oh look at that it's pretty
that's another thing about it like it's
one thing to have Oh stranger someone on
my side maybe or someone that I should
be worried about uh-oh
okay one A two nothing in there but it's
bound to be something on the south side
that's really cool they also make the
room sound different to give you like
the idea is that each room is actually a
room in like a real environment or not a
real environment but an environment in
this game and each one has its own
unique sound to give you the idea of
like the materials use well this is a
predicament I don't seem to have a way
around here ah there we go
super secret southwestern entrance
oh yeah you better run
I'm terrifying I'm super scary how am I
to know that the enemies are actually
enemies and they actually want to kill
me besides the fact that they kill me
deception oh so is this guy gonna try to
mess with me is it how this is gonna go
well
I am unmess with the ball
Oh No Oh God
okay that ain't good maybe the growling
should be an indication that they're
probably not good for me whoa whoa hey
hang on there
all right good thing they're slow holy
[ __ ] I think those way down to the south
there but I'm not sure it was a little
bizarre you'll never find me I'm super
still there I'm super stealthy yeah you
go the wrong way idiot okay oh yeah okay
not bad at all the only thing that I
worry about is there can only be so much
to this game considering it's the same
concept they need to innovate with new
features pretty soon or else it's just
gonna be the same thing repeated over
and over again in different layout which
is far why are they trapped in boxes
[ __ ]
I'm about to unleash them aren't I yeah
yep this is labyrinthian yeah Hey sorry
it's that thing just died whoa that was
my fault wasn't it Boosh
okay well they're just pockets of
monsters don't like that
oh that's not good either that's instant
death so it's gotta be something else
this is gonna spin me in circles over
and over again isn't it moving
yeah well that didn't sound good
well oh good okay that that was a big
that was a big those oh my good
silence I already know about sneaking I
already know I'm aware I am aware I've
been using this technique for a while I
am a very advanced gamer and I've been
playing for a long time okay so let me
be me and you can shut the [ __ ] up
oh how about okay well that was easy
okay then I already knew they were very
upset for a second there creep okay so
Who am I gonna be creeping on ah that's
who I'm gonna be creeping on the dead
bodies and the water droplets because
there's a lot of death over here and I
don't like it I know they place these
water droplets just to be able to guide
me along my way but I can do this oh I
think one of them just got out of the
place it escaped subterfuge what does
that mean am I gonna be doing the
distraction this time maybe
oh well Wow does that sound oh that's so
weird
I've always said that good horror games
have great audio and this is no
exception even though obviously the
entire game is based on the concept of
audio but not in an auditory like
listening sense it's it's a physical
manifestation of what audio is so of
course that has to be good but also you
know it complements it with actual good
sound design of the rooms and you can
tell how big the room you're in is and
you can tell what it is like made of and
all that other stuff that you oops
oh god I shouldn't you mean that three
bean salad huh dad
I can hold it down oh yeah oh good okay
I'm gone yeah so you can charge up your
stomps I didn't know that witness who's
gonna witness me there should be no
witnesses I'm gonna be all shiny and
chrome okay oh that did something yeah
who's that who's there Oh God
oh that's big oh that's very big oh he
made it out oh that is big whoa hey hey
buddy
dear buddy hey yeah I think I can walk
oh geez oh geez oh gosh oh gosh oh well
I see I gotta be like sneaky I gotta
wait for him to come by yeah yeah
literally the blob that ate it Hey
and you'll never catch me Wow I set off
a bomb with that door holy [ __ ]
nice interlock I don't know what that
means
oh that seems dangerous
okay what about you can't detect me you
have no idea so there's gotta be another
oh geez
it's got to be another opposite side
because of course it's gonna be duality
system like that no no you have no idea
you have no idea you have no idea I'm
out baby
I'm out baby I don't even need your a
notion that that's that's the opposite
of good I know what I'm doing I know
what I'm doing I'm like an expert at
this game didn't you know splash how
doesn't sound good my hair is weird at
the moment I apologize oh oh I can't
sneak in this can i oh no I cannot okay
that's interesting fascinating
fascinating oh it's so cool there's
gonna be like a oh it is it's like an
amnesia like water monster oh [ __ ] oh
god dude perfect okay we're fine we're
fine we're fine I think I'm gonna make
it to level 20 and then I'll probably
have a video there because I don't know
how many levels are in this game but if
you guys want to try this for yourself
this is really cool oh hi how's it going
oh geez let me just ah okay [ __ ]
well should've done that that was done
idea but he won't be able to tell where
I am until I'm already done
[ __ ] he knows where I am I'm not
already on yet perfect is it ah [ __ ]
well that's stupid idiot what a big dumb
goofy idiot okay there's probably gonna
be another one over here somewhere
probably I guess somewhere around here
what hmm okay I'm gonna do this hey okay
but then they're gonna go to the origin
point of this cuz yeah I figured there'd
be two of them then I can just sneak
around them and everything is gonna be
a-okay and then I won't have to transfer
the water which is the ideal because the
water is gonna generate noise no matter
what I do best to go around there we hey
again we did it what's next hole oh
we're introducing new concepts here what
am I supposed to pull am i pulling a
monster towards me huh
noop now yet that way what do we have
what am I looking at it's just a block
all right I'll go through the water then
I did all [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] oh ah pull pull the monster okay
I know I gotcha
I get tag attacked what and I
disappeared
how weird I'm gone just like that I
vanished into the night literally like a
shadow in the night okay so now I should
be able to walk fine and it doesn't
matter anyway
water was there okay but that's the end
of that okay so actually I'm an addict
here my voice is just crashed thank you
everybody so much for watching this game
is really cool like I don't know if it
justifies the price but I'll leave that
for you to decide so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next bye bye why are
my legs so itchy all
what is this game doing to me